hey guys Pete peppers here with candy
crush soda saga and this is the jelly
saga level 29 walkthrough with
commentary so we're gonna want to make
specialist and that's the first thing we
do that gives us a chance to send our
purple jam down and it also stuns the
clean and gives us an extra move so you
know this this level is frustrating for
a lot of reasons one of which is that
it's got a lot of color so it's hard to
make matches sweet there I didn't have
anything that was really important at
the top so I decided to make a match on
hers to drop it down and and this you
could see that sort of set this up to
where I could fire off my striped candy
and that's what I was you know that's
what I was intending to do there so
since I made another special I get
another move and I think I can just
spread out the purple on the bottom half
and yeah that's that's about it that's
about as good as I can hope for there so
what I'm doing is I'm checking the board
for specials first to stun the Queen and
if I can't find one then I'll just try
to you know figure out what the best
move is obviously I want to spread my
jam but there wasn't a there isn't
anything on the bottom to spread it out
right now so take another special there
and then here this kind of a decision do
I want to fire it off on the second row
to hit these fish or do I want to free
the other two fish and I think we're
right now I'm gonna hit the fish because
I'm wanting to keep the momentum that I
have going and those fish always sort of
get loose in the end anyways so not a
lot on the board right now I could free
that red fish it's not really that
important I think I you know I could
drop them here and see how it sets up
not really a bad result she blocked that
Queen red match on me but I can make
this fish here
and then Wow
not a whole lot but you know just trying
to keep in mind where I'm going with
setting up more chances to move down and
there we got lucky and we got a little
strike match here and the purple we're
gonna make that and I think we could
probably just set off this blue fish
only he's gonna cover one square but in
the end that's not gonna be how we're
going to cover it anyways we're gonna
have to set up a combo so make another
fish here with the green think I'm
checking the top first just to make sure
that I don't see another one that you
know on top that I can make first and I
can fire this off and a couple new
things to drop down depending on what
she does out here I can almost set up a
color bomb with this yellow I'm gonna
check the top first cuz see like I can
move the yellow and then move the green
sweet yeah so if she doesn't touch the
green here then I will do it for me I
guess so yeah so now I got a color bomb
at the bottom and I see there's a
striped here or a fish well yeah that's
gonna pretty much do it I'm gonna go
ahead and make this one at the top first
just to get the sparkling going and now
I'm gonna make this fish I know for sure
that I'll finish the level off
Sassy's I had the extra move there so
now I have the she's got this nice under
three times I get a little explosion
there and this is pretty much gonna you
know cover the rest of the board so this
is definitely a tough level a lot of
people have been asking and it took me a
few tries to get it going but you know
read the guide that I'm making this with
you know to try to keep try to get your
jam down I mean one of the things that's
hard is
her jams below so it's really hard to
set stuff up in the top because she'll
make a match underneath another mess
things up so just look for stripe
matches going down and then just look to
spread it out from side to side from
there hope this helps least that I'll
write more tips in the guide and if you
have any questions leave one here or and
I'll try to answer it as soon as I can
please subscribe to my channel so you
get more how-to and help videos and like
the video if you found it helpful thanks